Who Wants To Be A Millionaire changed
the game for game shows in the 2000s
seven figure prizes were a new way to
get eyeballs on shows that had been
around for decades including the Price
Is Right starting in 2003 CBS began
airing occasional Prime Time specials
called The Price is Right million
dollars spectacular but nobody won the
big bucks until 2008. Adam Rose a
teacher from Northern California told
the Shasta Herald that he waited all
night in the CBS parking lot to make
sure he was one of the first possible
audience members interviewed by
producers it took a little luck for his
name to get called to contestants row
where he successfully bit on a treadmill
then he played the grand game winning
twenty thousand dollars Rose's luck
continued and he got one of the spots in
the Showcase with a 70 Cent spin on the
wheel with a clutch bid just 880 below
the actual price of his showcase he
became the first Price Is Right
contestant to take home the million
dollar prize